und ich habe einfach mal richtig lust
drauf mich mit wirklich jedem zu treffen
der bock hat und deswegen würde ich
sagen mach mir so was mal flugs auf der
gamescom so ein kleines treffen
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einer ganz besonderen aufnahme denn wir
werden heute in zweierlei hinsicht etwas
ganz neues machen
zum aller ersten mal werden wir acht und
das müssen wir machen
im hintergrund mal ein bisschen musik
laufen lassen und die nicht ist nach
hinten reinstellen das will ich erstmal
ausprobieren
wir können wir sagen was ihr davon
haltet ich glaube die musik muss jetzt
richtig laut genug sein
ich hoffe es und die zweite besonderheit
ist es ist halb vier nachts aber ich
hätte gerne einen richtigen
motivationsschub
ok jetzt kollege machst du mal ein video
jetzt fast immer bock geiler das ist ein
bisschen schöner anfang sloot und warum
mache ich jetzt ein video mitternacht
nein ich habe nicht nur gut sondern ist
auch ein thema das ich besprechen will
und zwar würde ich gerne mal schon so
die ersten claims abstecken bzw
mal das erste mal über die gamescom 2014
reden
richtig die gamescom 2014 weil ich da
sein werde voraussichtlich ich glaube
schon also das müsste ich ziemlich
selbst an dass ich da bin und markieren
sie wegschmelzen können hieß es eltern
so richtig wm stars in chaträumen
natürlich nicht es geht darum dass ich
einfach mal von euch gerne hören würde
von euch zuschauern werden sobald der
gamescom 2014 am start ist und wer dann
vielleicht sogar noch eventuell bock auf
dem fantreffen hatte hätte nicht hatte
weil es wird in der zukunft geschehen
hätte konjunktiv nicht vergangenheit
genau jetzt ein bisschen deutsch
unterricht gemacht super wird man war
stolz auf mich schreib doch einfach mal
in die kommentare
wer von euch auf der gamescom ist und
bock hat auf so ein fantreffen das würde
mich mal interessieren und im
allgemeinen freue ich mich aber so
riesig auf die gamescom weil man endlich
mal die ganzen youtube trifft mit dem
man die ganze zeit aufnimmt voll geil
ja komm du musst nur weg hier also
sowohl damit man nicht so wohl
auch das schlechte taten ich glaub es
nicht ich lasse es nicht jetzt kommen
her komm her gibt mir eine diamanten den
habe ich mir hat er kämpft gegen den
typen da habe ich nicht aber von
weggeschnitten ziemlich gerettet hat
sozusagen flowers nicht hat mich sogar
noch bitkom jetzt minerals lp was dieser
name ja so ok danke
lange will ich mal sagen ja sehr weise
jetzt hier eine survival games runde
auszuwählen um ein thema zu besprechen
aber so kennt man mich ja ich muss schon
durch so schnell los
ja auf jeden fall freue ich mich richtig
richtig richtig doll auf die gamescom
einerseits war ich dann endlich mal
einfach ja richtig richtig viele
abonnenten nochmal treffen kann wir
hatten ja man dieses kleine fan treffen
in berlin
aber natürlich war jetzt nicht so viele
leute da es war unglaublich insgesamt
naja 20 30 leute oder so davon sind die
meisten noch von max und ich hoffe mal
mega bock mal so die ganzen s kids dazu
sehen vielleicht auch die die eine
relativ weite anreise haben und
dementsprechend nicht so bei den
spontanen fern treffen dabei sein können
da denke ich zum beispiel an jetzt den
hackl oder so oder den er grüße euch
beide die natürlich schon relativ lange
dabei und ich kommen beide aus
österreich sind aber das glaube ich
sogar nachbarn und haben dementsprechend
natürlich so leichte probleme einfach
mal spontan nach berlin zu kommen sind
grob geschätzt 1500 km
ihr könnt mich mal korrigieren in den
kommentaren auf jeden fall ist es nicht
so einfach und ich habe einfach mal
richtig lust drauf mich mit wirklich
jedem zu treffen
der bock hat und deswegen würde ich
sagen mach mir so was mal flugs auf der
gamescom so ein kleines treffen und vor
allem auch deswegen es macht halt auch
wirklich jeder der irgendwo entfernt
treffen und ist einfach geil weil so
viele youtube wie auf dem jupiter der
ist es nicht das ist was anderes aber
videodreh auf der so viel ja soviel
youtube gibts eigentlich nirgendwo sonst
und da habe ich halt mega lust darauf
mitzumachen der rennt jetzt werke team
hinterher
ein kollege macht es natürlich hier die
smarte abkürzung und hier macht man
nochmals matte abkürzung okay es war
nicht so schmal
dann geht das war zwei mal richtig knapp
gar nicht so schlecht gelaufen das hat
mich zwar irgendwie getroffen aber nicht
mal halbes schaden gemacht als perón
auffinden stil also wirklich alle
register kommt hallo hallo ich trete
nicht bist du mich verarschen
ich fass es nicht ich fass es nicht
jetzt ist natürlich ja schon fast ein
ganzes feuerzeug kaputtgespart an uns
und ich laufe auch noch so gut wie die
zwei halt trinken meine fresse das ist
natürlich immer so bisschen ärgerlich
wenn er so einer so richtig richtig mit
allem was er hat
finden es bleibt aber meist noch nicht
super von mir gelaufen
andererseits ist ein bisschen schwierig
wenn einfach überall das feuer ist aus
der physik vip hat das sieht aus dem
stein schwert wenn wir jetzt einen
kurzen turner dort machen jetzt auch
noch weiter um gut und gut
jetzt mal weg schade schade schade wir
gehen auch mal kurz einen cut wir gehen
einen katheter oder vielleicht machen
wir doch keine 180 sekunden nehmen muss
weil ich keinen kopf machen
mario freut sich der schneider das spart
sich die arbeit der schneider vor allen
dingen es hört sich an als wenn ich
irgendwie so schneider halt kenne so
schneider so schneider schneider
diese klamotten schneidern und sorgten
kennt man das ja das kennt man ach schön
zweifel games4mac hat die 20 gar nicht
verdient dass natürlich dass sich harte
worte man lieber maß 98 gerade weil sie
doch schon sehr lange dabei ist und auch
schon viele videos gemacht hat nicht
merke gerade dass die musik im mainboard
so ein bisschen lauter ist gerade aber
das sollte kein problem sein
das sollte eigentlich kein problem sein
ich habe heute auch bisschen schädiger
jazz mass im hintergrund und man nicht
wie immer hausmusik einfach ein bisschen
abwechslung dazu bringen ich denke dass
es auch in eurem sinne weil ich habe
immer das gefühl wenn ihm mal die
gleiche musik kommt also wirklich auf
teufel komm raus immer das gleiche wird
es auch langweilig war schön läuft
eigentlich richtig schöne rüste haben
wir hier haben wir schon die sechs
punkte vor
jetzt so jasch werden wir auch mit
apotheken auf die einst diana wochen so
und dann gehen wir mal auf die jagd nach
vorne die 1 hinten
ja genau kollege ja super duo ganze
zweck dass es mir egal wo ich mir
irgendwann zeug macht doch hoffte willst
du probe zwickl ja ok sehr gut wägen wir
hat keine lust sich jetzt gerade so zu
boxen hab ich's gefühl
deswegen suche ich einfach noch weiter
hier meine stadt die route ab also das
ist so stand man hier immer der bahnhof
und dann hier in das gebäude ein
da vorne ich kann auch noch mal die
zusatz route zeigen eigentlich die ich
laufe also wenn es richtig gut läuft und
hier eigentlich fast keiner ist dann
gehe ich teilweise noch mal die zu ärzte
auch du bist aber auch ein spezi alter
und jetzt wegrennen erhält ist nicht
dein ernst das ist nicht dein ernst da
hinten es wahrscheinlich auch den
partnern
herr kollege dafür steckt mir jetzt mal
so sagt paar und erst mit jetzt 5 modus
sich davon hier dreht sich um ein
bisschen übungen hätten kollege ist
nicht ist nicht den trick hab ich auch
von jonas 2 22 46 okay ich kann nicht so
gut wie der dass man auf der auf dem
gelände läuft aber ich muss erst mal ein
steak schmecken
da hilft alles nichts wir müssen erstmal
snacken
so jetzt bist du weg kollege ach nee
also so hatte ich das nicht gemeint mit
bis zu weg ich hatte gehofft es springt
ins wasser
das natürlich auch
kritisch so was da denke ich mir auch
immer so suboptimal wenn solche leute
einfach weiß er gibt schon hat ziemlich
sicher mit dem anderen geteilt würde ich
mal sagen falls nicht sorry dann
beschuldigte jetzt hier falsch gemacht
welche entschuldigung das will ich
natürlich auch nicht aber es sei doch
stark danach aus
er ist der nächste und ehrt ihn
hallo wie der junge tnt spam ist er
richtig tnt rich muss man sagen sagt
zack zack dafür was jetzt auch mit dir
ach ja echt kein schatten im wasser
daran nicht gedacht da hast du nicht
gedacht kommt stirbt anleger so boris t
und ihre möbel bild hätte und jetzt gut
zerbersten können aber wenn man im
wasser ist trifft enthielt er glaube ich
nicht ich glaube so ist das dorf oder
könnt ihr mir auch mal die kommentare
schreiben
aber ich meine das so in erinnerung zu
haben ich mag das nämlich einfach so
einfach bei musik somit zu singen ich
bin einfach ich bin so ein mensch der
sich mega gerne mit auch wenn überhaupt
nicht singen kann
ach komm jetzt hey hallo junge du willst
du doch verarschen
warum wetten hier kommt jetzt hoch ja
warum da vorne nicht ganz ehrlich fragt
doch nur mega abbruch ich hasse so was
diese fuße leider am wasser unerträglich
weil dann geht's weiter geht's weiter
geht's nächste schnitzel runde
foto win oder vorne ich weiß nicht durch
der tin
ja mei dann bereitet ändern kommt motto
kraft fertig backen boden alter das ist
unfassbar
ich mag einfach so auf dem boden
aufgekommen dann verstehe ich denn davon
einfach mal das fahrzeug nicht gut
gebrauchen
das nächste gegner schaue man die
richtung falls sich anschleichen
wollen sollte ich hoffe das war korrekt
ist
das mache ich auch immer so sowohl bei
energie entweichen games einfach immer
in die richtung vom nächsten gegner
positionieren
da wurde in diesem haus drin ach ja und
du kommst wieder zurück jetzt denkst du
kann sich verarschen die wettlauf
bogenschießen nummer junge ich bin muss
ein bisschen früher aufstehen man lieber
dafür dass ich dich verschiedene cholera
vorder wie bei mama ich blocke die
glocke ja kaum was machst du jetzt jetzt
läuft weg so deftig kommt vier leute
runter nach dieser mod mad mad kraft es
nicht noch kräfte von matt der so
komplett umrüstung ist das alles kein
problem
kreuz hat uns gerettet in diesen weg weg
weg weg fakt an uns zu viele hits
gegeben
kaka das war so leider bisschen nicht so
toll ja aber wissen was minuten ich
würde sagen wenn euch diese talkrunde
mal so gefallen hat
so richtig spät jolo mäßig dann einfach
einen daumen nach oben da lassen
wie gesagt in die kommentare schreiben
wer zur gamescom gehen will
wer bock auf dem fantreffen hat dann
würde ich sagen
haut rein check noch den mitspieler
niemand apn den kräutern den kommentaren
völlig es ist später hatte ich lass
einfach das gelaber unrein macht's gut